[Music]
uh well Noel here I have an article for
you from the NY post one of the most
reputable
uh newspapers and media Outlets
yes I believe they broke the official
numbers on the Holocaust so they did and
now they're back with another great
article this one's from January 7th uh
the headline day after the celebration
hot
yep
the headline here is I started dating a
sex doll after my fiance left me I even
introduced her to my mom
and uh you see a nice little picture of
the two of them
beautiful I hope that they use that for
their Christmas card
let's read this yeah sure pop down
after a devastating breakup in years
without physical intimacy Rod made the
Bold move to purchase a two thousand and
sixty four dollar sex doll named Karina
or Karina Maybe
uh the Aussie Carpenter from rural New
South Wales had been left Frozen in a
state of loneliness in 2021 when he
ordered Karina online after searching
for sexual stimulation tools insane
Google
sexual stimulation tools this guy's just
emailing DeWalt hey you got anything I
could put my dick in
he's pulling up at Home Depot
so where's the sexual stimulation aisle
I'm looking for a tool
for another kind of wood
uh despite having zero knowledge about
sex dolls the 54 year old said Karina
changed his life in many ways and
finally gave him something to care for
the doll became my synthetic physical
companion rod rod told Mamma Mia
slowly my heart opened up and I was
distracted from my grief of losing my ex
that just wouldn't go away by itself
huh ex-fiance by the way only two months
after purchasing Karina Rod made the big
mistake or the big decision sorry to
introduce her to his mom in Victoria for
Christmas
mom basically looked at her as if she
was poison Rod told 7 News tisk tisk
Mother
come on you know what I mean come on Mom
uh the 85 year old was shocked but after
some encouragement Rod's mom was picking
out jewelry and clothes for Karina in
the end she warmed up it was like a long
lost daughter she really got into it he
said
the trade he bought this is where it
gets kind of weird the treaty bought
another sex doll named Lauren for a
discounted price of two thousand dollars
who Rod describes as a Daydreamer and
Karina's sister
Rod also started a long-distance
relationship with a woman named Jenny
from Vietnam not long after purchasing
his two dolls it's like where
where emotionally is this guy you know
well first of all
love the I don't know if it's irony but
I just love the fact that his name is
Rod like of course it is yeah exactly
yeah Rod sticks it in his two new
sex dolls uh also
what what dude in Vietnam is cleaning
him out by way of the is
of his digital footprint as Jenny yeah
exactly
like hit this guy has three fake
relationships
while the couple are now happily engaged
the tradie claims that uh there were
quote tense moments when Jenny
discovered Laura and Karina well first
of all how do you discover them remotely
like you think he just forget to like
like in your frame right now on the zoom
like they'd be sitting on the couch and
he'd be like oh [__]
who's sitting on the couch back there
grid and he's like the [__] is that
hey Rod do you have company she accepted
my hobby
after some time and often would help me
with some advice
Rod said his dolls keep him company when
he can't be with Jenny he uses his spare
time to Bath dress pamper and photograph
them that's cute
since purchasing the dolls Rod has taken
an interest in photography and manages
an Instagram account Karina lovely
dedicated to Karina's modeling shots
yeah is it is it like a business because
oh is this real
okay all right let's have a look
hi oh Jenny's real
Karina is my love doll I have been with
my human girl Jenny from Vietnam for
nearly my human girl
from Vietnam for nearly two years she
loves how Karina keeps me company when
she can't happy New Year damn
wow
this is the pipeline for the passport
Bros
who are the best boys
uh you ain't heard about this like these
dudes that you know
claim that foreign women aren't as
difficult as American women so they oh
yeah yeah
that whole
yeah there is there a term for
what they have an only fans come on man
who is paying to see a manic I was about
to say maybe he like turned it into a
business oh who is down horrific that
they are paying to see mannequin titties
it's like you can just buy one
you can spend money on a real one oh my
goodness dude
this is oh
this is crazy
yeah wait go back to the Instagram I'm
not done with Instagram let's let's
let's focus on you know let's look at
the photography yeah let's see let's
okay honestly that's pretty fire some of
those yeah some of those other shots
were pretty decent these aren't so great
these are terrifyingly human bro no
they're not
some some of the first ones not those
ones the ones like from a distance where
you can't really get a good read dude
this is they get you for Sally it's like
almost good
that's what I mean is I'm not I'm not
judging it like one to one with human
I guess oh so scary it's like this is
like I save America World Police yeah
dude actually I guess when I say
terrifyingly human it's I mean
it's like to a point where
starting to become human yeah like it's
still not good but yeah like oh okay
this is bridging a gap yeah
I mean you know it's nice that he found
a new passion
yeah dude
some of these shots are extremely mid
[Laughter]
we should buy his only fans just to
leave those comments mid cool dog image
sucks rod these are mid dude you gotta
yeah what the [__] is this this blown
out ass lighting come on man you're
gonna tease me some Wanderlust you got
to make this [__] oh that one's bad
what the the [__] the
the wigs
yeah dude is he just simulating incest
here yeah what the [__] come on rod
sick caption I hope you feel good
what else we got
the hands are not real at all and it
makes you so creeped
dude what are these comments man the
modern doll best invention since beer
uh I don't know if that's true how long
can one keeps these 10 years looking for
payment plan five thousand and one go is
tough
damn dude oh
can you imagine you're [__] dude
Credit Karma hits you up your credit
score has improved straight to the bank
I need a personal loan for 5K
and then it costs another 2K because
this [__] you know this [__] weighs like
180 pounds yeah
what do you think it's made of
I don't know
it's got to be some like really dense
material I feel we have one on the ship
we have Tatiana
yeah but yeah mannequin isn't she no
she's a sex doll
what wait chatiana that we use in the
moment House shows
oh that's right oh yeah oh yeah yeah
that thing was super heavy so yeah I
forgot about her we should set her up
and take some Glamor Shots
for her yo let's make it only fans who
knows this guy could be raking it in
that's the thing about only fans is like
these weird little niches like make so
much more money dude no scroll down to
the in the blue
[__] that dude that made the smile I
would throw that out the window get out
of here bro yo New Nightmare just
dropped
holy [__] nah nightmare nightmare yo
save that and then when one of your
friends is on shrooms show them that